[Music]
the red
planet has played an essential role in
mythologies and astrology
and has been deeply ingrained in
cultures for centuries
it wasn't until we got a telescope in
hand that we saw mars for its potential
well elon musk did his company spacex
has been developing a program to allow
colonizing our neighboring planet
and it includes the usage of fully
reusable launch vehicles
on-orbit propellant tanks rapid
turnaround launch
and landing mounts and production of
rocket fuel on mars
so there are some big plans in motion to
take the human civilization to mars
elon musk along with his team is running
around
executing some of the most extraordinary
feats
mankind has ever seen but what's the
plan
when we actually get there welcome back
to our channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring the bell
so you never miss an upload from us
while elon musk is best known for his
electric car
giant tesla his space program is hotly
discussed in the news 2.
founded in 2002 the aim of space
exploration technologies corp
or spacex was to reduce the cost of
space transportation
to allow colonization of mars they
manufacture the falcon 9 and falcon
heavy launch vehicles
rocket engines and the starlink
satellites
in 2001 musk conceptualized mars oasis
where a miniature experimental
greenhouse would be sent to mars to grow
plants
in order to make it happen he started to
build the affordable rockets he needed
spacex developed its first orbital
launch with falcon 1
an expendable small lift launch vehicle
the total development cost came to 90
million dollars
and it was funded privately in 2005
spacex announced plans to pursue a human
rated commercial space program
through the end of the decade a program
which would later become
the dragon spacecraft around this time
elon musk also made his plans for
colonizing mars known
according to him we should get out of
here before there's a world war
iii in 2012 spacex launched the first
commercial spacecraft to deliver cargo
to the international space station
they also started their active
reusability test program
by testing low altitude low speed
aspects of the landing technology
and just a year later they launched
their first commercial mission for a
private customer
in 2017 elon musk revealed the bigger
plan for mars
to get one million people to the red
planet for colonization spacex would do
with their interplanetary transport
system
which can carry 100 people per flight
the rocket will also likely have movie
theaters
lecture halls and a restaurant more
luxuries than nasa's restaurants got
when they were crammed into a capsule
and heading to the moon
according to elon musk it's going to be
an enjoyable journey
by 2018 spacex had over a hundred
launches under their belt
representing 12 billion us dollars in
contract revenue
both from government and commercial
customers and in the following year
they announced their starship and
starlink projects
they launched 60 satellites to form a
satellite constellation around the earth
and in 2020 spacex successfully launched
two nasa astronauts into orbit on a crew
dragon spacecraft
from the kennedy space center in florida
they also announced plans to be a long
duration
cargo and passenger spacecraft as the
second stage of a reusable launch
vehicle
musk has made it clear that spacex does
not plan to create settlements
it would be up to the settlers to build
anything they want spacex is merely
providing the transport
he hopes it will grow into a
self-sufficient colony
but getting there would require many
more elements
high net worth individuals companies and
even governments
so when will we finally get there
an uncrewed starship rocket is set to
launch in 2024
but the date has always wavered musk's
aspirational timeline was for spacex to
send cargo ships to mars in 2022
followed by a crude mission a year later
later
this was pushed to 2024 fewer than five
percent of spacex's employees are
working on the interplanetary transport
system right now
so we expect the date to be pushed
further musk
is known to give some pretty ambitious
timelines but if his projections are
accurate spacex's first mars mission
will line up with nasa astronauts
returning from the moon under the
artemis program
the journey to mars will take
approximately 115 days
and cost 500 000 per person
but in 2016 elon musk said he believed
that the price could come down to
hundred thousand dollars in the long
term so what
happens when the first people actually
reach the red planet
habitats the first temporary habitats
will be the starships themselves
and they will be well equipped with life
support systems
only the starship cargo flights will
return to earth
probably to collect gear and materials
belonging to the boring company
that's right elon musk's other venture
the boring company
may be responsible for making tunnels
under the surface of mars
to create underground habitats for the
astronauts and early settlers
while conditions on both earth and mars
are somewhat similar
the surface of mars is not hospitable to
humans
or really most life forms because of the
radiation
reduced air pressure and 0.16
oxygen in the atmosphere human survival
here
would require artificial habitats with
complex life support systems
food speaking of survival the question
arises how will the first settlers eat
no system has been put in place for that
yet well
the first astronauts there will take a
minimum two year supply of vacuum-sealed
packets of food
just like the ones used on the
international space station
they may not rely on mars-grown food
much
but there will experimentation with
growing food to see if they can
substitute their packaged food
for fresh produce space exploration
vehicle
after accommodation and food are sorted
it's time to map the surface of mars
if you want to do productive exploration
anywhere in space
you'll need a suitable vehicle for which
nasa developed the space exploration
vehicle
it's a pressurized vehicle that can room
four astronauts for up to 72 hours
it features a cabin mounted on a chassis
with wheels that can pivot
360 degrees and go six miles an hour
in any direction it's about the size of
the pickup truck with
12 wheels and it even contains sleeping
and sanitary facilities
it was designed to need zero or very
little maintenance
with several of these on the surface of
mars astronauts will be able to travel
more than
125 miles in any direction
terraforming if we plan to make mars our
home
it will take large scale ecological
engineering
otherwise known as terraforming we
already know
mars had a denser atmosphere and was
once warm enough to maintain oceans
so terraforming it would essentially
mean restoring it to its past
self to do this early visitors will have
to warm up the planet
thicken the atmosphere and make the
atmosphere breathable
this can be achieved by triggering a
greenhouse effect with ammonia ices from
the outer solar system being
impacted on the surface in addition to
being a powerful greenhouse gas
ammonia is mostly nitrogen by weight so
it could provide the necessary buffer
gas which
when combined with oxygen would create a
breathable atmosphere for humans
spacex also plans to build a solar
powered factory on mars
that will use the carbon dioxide and
water ice in the planet's air and soil
to generate methane and oxygen and
another of musk's ventures will be used
on mars to provide a communication link
for settlers there
his starlink constellations will
eventually move from earth to mars
for that purpose currently spacex is
hoping to start its cargo missions using
its starship program by 2022
followed by the first crude flight in
2024.
we might expect a permanent mars base in
2028 according to elon musk
they are even planning a tourist mission
around to moon in 2023
but why stop there elon musk's
presentation in 2016
also outlined his plans for missions to
enclades
a saturnian moon europa and a fuel depot
on pluto
among other things the aim is to open up
the solar system to the human race
saturn and pluto are still a long way
away but it's exciting to think of the
possibilities
understandably the mars project requires
a financial commitment too extreme for
any government the u.s government
certainly
doesn't have the budget for colonizing
mars so
the planet is essentially open for big
businesses to invest in
but building settlements and
establishing businesses aside
it is remarkable what spacex has done so
far
as we get closer to becoming an
interplanetary species
we better appreciate the sheer ingenuity
of the human mind
think you'll take the next step and be
one of the first
settlers on mars let us know in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
give us a like and check out more over
on the simply tech
channel thanks for watching and we'll
see you
next time